[Música]
el hombre no llego a la luna la tierra
es plana darwin no tenía ninguna razón
descendemos de los reptiles
en el año 2016 la universidad de oxford
sazona con mucha mucho esto que está
diciendo lo sé
empezó a hablar por una vez de la pos
verdad la real academia española define
este neologismo como aquella información
basada en hechos no objetivos que apelan
a nuestras emociones a nuestras
creencias y nuestros deseos
mi nombre es jabón por mi nombre javier
fabrice honrando a mis padres presentes
pero soy jabón mago algo así como un
mentiroso profesional en lo que me he
vuelto un me dedico al sutil arte del
engaño
como artista entendí que el asombro es
lo principal es mi arte porque a partir
de allí podemos desarrollar el arte
porque justamente el asombro nos vuelve
vulnerables nos hace de tierra fértil a
que cualquier mentira que anda dando
vueltas entre penetre en nuestro ser es
verdad es que 'news codiciosas campañas
electorales
publicidades etcétera
es cierto que los magos también sabemos
muy bien que las mecánicas del engaño
funcionan en aquellos lugares hitos
vacíos que dejan nuestro cerebro y que
nuestro cerebro mismo nosotros mismos
rellenamos cada vez que anticipamos cada
vez que asumimos cada vez que
prejuzgamos
pareciera que estoy definiendo la
intuición de hecho lo estoy haciendo
pero la intuición es algo muy poderoso
que nos hace humanos en primer lugar
pero también es algo que nos puede
llegar a jugar en contra se los voy a
ejemplificar supongamos por un instante
que yo tengo o propongo hacer un efecto
de magia en donde un mazo de cartas se
ordena automáticamente mediante
solamente un clic de cartas se ordena
del as al rey cartas rojas cartas negras
muy sencillo bueno tengo dos caminos
como artista puedo ir a luego vio
mostrarles un mazo desordenado
más ordenado la gente se asombra es un
camino un poco más largo por las cosas
que tenemos que hacer en el medio pero a
veces los artistas de ilusión y también
los mentirosos utilizamos lo que se
llama implantar una idea general
un concepto que hace que nosotros mismos
nos engañemos y que el artista no haga
casi nada y lo voy a explicar si yo
utilicé que hacer esto diría con
convicción marzo de cartas mezclado en
mis manos
es una mentira que está este mazo de
cartas mezclado de hecho ahora sé lo que
mostrar está perfectamente ordenado de
antemano pero dicho entre dos verdades
la verdad cubre la mentira y la mentira
pasa verdad mentira verdad de esta forma
nos engañan todo el tiempo es un
mecanismo que utilizamos los artistas
para hacer un montón de cosas el mazo
está perfectamente ordenado no sé si se
llega a ver bien
sin embargo
los seres humanos tenemos otra gran
virtud que es la capacidad que tenemos
para asombrarnos con las curiosidades
somos curiosos entonces nos detenemos
casi siempre a pensar en ese caso en uno
en un millón no es tómate un vasito de
vino que vas a vivir más tiempo y así
vamos todas las noches a emborracharnos
si este por cierto la comunidad
artística me odia a partir de este
momento los magos digo
creemos más en artistas en la gente que
aparece en la tele que a veces en
grandes expertos pero ahora eso sí si
tenemos un tema jorobado de salud vamos
directamente a ver la eminencia que
mayor casos de éxito comprobados puede
tener los magos no sólo somos los
artífices de muchas de estas
formas de engañar pero tampoco somos los
únicos así se esconden gente estafadores
gente que tiene algún beneficio a partir
de manipular nuestra voluntad pero me
las post verdades en sí me llaman más la
atención todavía porque hay algunas que
parecieran no tener un beneficiario
final han tomado sustento se han creado
asociaciones de gente que cree
determinadas cosas y a partir de ahí las
defiende hagamos una pequeña
primero casi se sale
con convicción sin pensar en el qué
dirán levanten la mano si hay una
persona que crea que la tierra es plana
bien después no existe un hombre por
favor
levanten ahora la mano a las personas
que crean que el hombre nos llevó a la
luna y que fue todo un fake una especie
de programa de televisión que pasaron en
el 69
algunos más levantaron la mano ya con un
poquito más d
de convicción no
lo cierto es que
el hombre llegó a la luna no si la
tierra es plana o no
son cuestiones que determinan lo que
sabemos versus lo que creemos y los
seres humanos muchas veces elegimos los
argentinos es más lo hacemos más a
menudo
elegimos creer que sabemos
versus saber
hablar con que se sienten más cómodos yo
sólo sé que no creo nada o solo yo sólo
creo que no sé nada
para que se lo pregunten ustedes parecía
están librándose como una especie de
batalla entre la pos verdad que son
estos disparates y la pro verdad que es
como se han denominado los dueños de la
verdad verdadera que desmiente con
evidencia la verdad no tuvieron mejor
idea que ponerle un nombre a esto lo que
le saca un poco que cree diría en lo que
a mí me parece pues verdad en serio pero
verdad es como una especie de cosa ahí
medio ridícula lo cierto es que el
décimo segundo hombre en pisar la luna y
el último en hacerlo después de seis
misiones exitosas de la serie a polo el
comandante del apolo 17 dio todo esto
con los que levantaron la mano la razón
ratita
eugene cernan decía
que la verdad no necesita ser defendida
francamente cuando
empecé a pensar en el cierre de la
charla
trate de buscar recetas para que las
sean víctimas de las verdades
había muchas algunas más comprobables
que otras pero como mago encontré la que
creo que tengo la teoría para decirle
que es que cuando escuché en una verdad
leer una noticia y les parezca por
extremo asombrosa por lo menos permitan
saludarlo
antes de retweet ar
lo cierto es que no todo el asombro es
la puerta del engaño cuando vean un mago
por ejemplo como vuelvan a ver en alguna
ocasión ahí si relájense no dejes de
llevar
porque como les digo no todo el asombro
es la puerta al engaño
o sí
a lo mejor dije algunas cuestiones para
que crean que un mazo de cartas
mezclado en mis manos ahora finalmente
este
completamente mezclado de verdad
a lo mejor dije esto
para mostrarles
y ni siquiera había cartas en primer
lugar
lo cierto es que
solo con el corazón se puede creer
y lo esencial es increíble los ojos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]